bonjour à vous karine besse i go l'ofco
alors évidemment l'ukraine a largement
dominé cette cet entretien accordé à rtl
à moscou le ministre des affaires
étrangères russe qui a souligné c'est
vrai les accusations récurrentes de
l'occident envers les agissements de la
russie du côté de l'ukraine mais dans le
même temps il a rappelé aussi que kiev
ne respectait pas forcément ses
engagements pris dans le cadre des
accords de minsk
bonjour oui effectivement l'ukraine est
le sujet central
actuellement en géopolitique puisque
c'est le thème qui a été choisi par les
états unis le camp atlantis pour cibler
leurs habitats contre la russie pour
continuer à construire l'image de
l'agression russe de la menace de la
russie
sachant que il présente une vision qui
totalement biaisée des des événements et
de la situation qu'ils oublient de
signifier par exemple que c'est l'armée
ukrainienne qui attaquent les civils du
donbass ce n'est pas l'armée russe qui
attaquent kiev que la russie mène sur
son propre territoire des exercices
militaires donc qui n'ont pas des
prétentions à être agressif pour les
pays voisins puisque ce sont des
exercices sur son propre territoire à la
différence des programmes de l'otan dont
les des armées a notamment américaines
canadiennes et cetera se retrouve à
quelques milliers de kilomètres de chez
elle se retrouve à former des militaires
qui vont ukrainien qui vont attaquer les
uns et violé les accords de minsk et des
entre guillemets formateur qui sont de
plus en plus proche de la frontière de
l'allier deux tirs donc il y as si vous
voulez une un discours qui est pré
formatés qui est là pour créer une
certaine image et consolider autour de
washington
un ensemble de pays qui commence à de
plus en plus quand même hésité parce que
l'on voit la grande bretagne par exemple
qui a déclaré il ya quelques jours ne
pas être prête à envoyer des soldats
britanniques en ukraine pour se battre
aux comptes aux côtés de l'armée
craignent n si par hasard on sait jamais
il y avait réellement une agression
russe donc la situation n'est pas si
simple que ça pour les états unis et
c'est peut-être aussi ce qui explique
cette
radicalisation du discours alors
justement le ministre des affaires
étrangères russe a assemblé pointe et
l'inertie des occidentaux
concernant justement l'application des
accords du mix qu'il ya eu un entretien
il l'a rappelé sergueï lavrov entre le
président russe l'a dit mr poutine et
son homologue français emmanuel macron
donc il serait question peut-être d'une
réunion à venir en format normandie donc
avec l'allemagne la france l'ukraine et
la russie vous croyez que cette réunion
elle aura lieu
cette réunion peut avoir lieu comme
beaucoup de réunions ont lieu qui
finalement concrètement ne permettent
pas de régler la situation puisque le
problème est actuellement dans une
incompatibilité totale des positions
entre la position de la russie est celle
unis et des pays qui sont alliés des
etats unis
nous sommes confrontés ici aussi une
espèce de mise en scène occidental dans
laquelle les accords de minsk doivent
être exécutés en fait par la russie et
c'est la russie qui est à chaque fois
visée parce que l'ukraine qui elle est
visée par ces accords de mixte ne les
exécute pas alors que la russie elle est
garante de l'exécution de ces de ces
accords ce n'est pas elle qui doit
modifier la constitution ukrainienne ce
n'est pas elle qui doit retirer les
troupes ukrainienne du donbass sinon à
ce moment là on irait quand même la
souveraineté de l'ukraine
donc il est effectivement possible qu'il
y ait une nouvelle rencontre à nos
vaisseaux mais même si ces derniers
temps les dirigeants russes à demande
d'abord à ce qu'il y ait certaines
avancées concrètes rappelant que
discuter pour discuter pour l'instant ça
me conduit à rien et l'on voit que la
situation ne s'améliore pas du tout d'en
bas en tout cas ce n'est pas nouveau et
ce même en nouveau sommet normandie qui
permettra de résoudre le problème du
dombass que c'est un problème politique
c'est une question de rapport de force
les autorités ukrainiennes qui sont les
marionnettes du du clan atlantis est des
états unis ont besoin
que ce conflit soit actif donc ils ne
peuvent pas se permettre de le résoudre
donc ils ne peuvent pas se permettre
d'exécuter les accords de minsk ce n'est
pas dans l'intérêt des états unis les
états unis ont besoin de garder sur
confié actifs afin de pouvoir continuer
à accuser la russie alors il concernant
toujours l'ukraine sergueï lavrov a
évoqué aussi les inquiétudes du kremlin
vis-à-vis de la progression d'une
progression de l'otan aux frontières de
la russie ça c'est une préoccupation
majeure aussi pour le kremlin qui est
qui est accusé de préparer une invasion
par en ukraine par les occidentaux
si la russie avait voulu intervenir
réellement en ukraine elle aurait pu le
faire en 2015 en fin 2014 derrière
derrière le maïdan ça n'a pas été fait
parce que la russie n'a pas intérêt
justement à envahir l'ukraine elle n'a
pas intérêt à une guerre on écrème est
là à accepter
que la crimée soit rattachée à la russie
puisque suite au coup d'état du maidan
l'état ukrainien en tant qu'etat à s'est
désagrégé les partie ukrainienne ont
donc eu le droit de récupérer
juridiquement leur autonomie ce qu'a
fait le crime est ce qu elle l'a déclaré
à partir du moment où
la russie n'est même pas intervenue
militairement pour
récupérer le dombass on peut sourire
face à ces accusations de prochaine
invasion de l'armée et craignait surtout
rappelons qu'il ya quelques années de ça
1 devant la cour de la et l'ukraine
avait demandé aussi certaines garanties
face à l'agression russe et à l'invasion
russe et le tribunal de la haye n'avait
à l'époque pas trouvé de preuves d'une
présence militaire russe en ukraine la
situation n'a pas changé de ce côté là
ce qui change c'est que la politique
atlantiste s'est radicalisée et elle a
besoin de faire monter la pression pour
faire céder la russie dans un sens ou
dans l'autre et c'est ce rapport de
force auquel on assiste actuellement
effectivement m un des armes de l'otan
en ukraine militarisé encore plus le
pays alors qu'il ya un conflit ouvert
met en danger la sécurité
internationales sur le continent
européen puisque si la russie est là
n'est pas en position de vouloir
agresser de vouloir attaquer en revanche
et elle l'a prévenue elle ne se laissera
pas attaqué non plus elle sera bientôt
j'étais défendre merci beaucoup à vous à
karine bêcher golovkov on sait
décryptage rappelle que vous êtes
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou